he just started learning cantonese which
is probably because when you see where
he is he just not just it's been a while
now i've been following on twitter moved
to hong kong so he's learning cantonese
i guess he could um go around and
communicate better
so please welcome coming live from hong
kong cesari
great well uh thanks so much for having
me and uh thanks for that warm
introduction i uh i am indeed here in
hong kong where i my wife and i moved
out here last year um i'm a data
investigative journalist it's what i've
been doing now most of my career and
last year we moved out here and i
started teaching
data and financial journalism at hong
kong university
while pursuing projects for propublica
and it's been really fun um you'll be
glad to know that your copy your
autographed copy of r for everyone uh
made the cut for what we put on the
container ship to come out here to hong
kong because i now teach r uh for my
journalism students uh at uh at uh uh
hong kong university so it's been it's
been a real treat and actually you
mentioned cantonese cantonese makes it a
little bit easier to explain some of the
core concepts of our like our being case
sensitive you know
from learning cantonese you know there's
a big difference in tones we say
yup versus
are you saying monday are you saying
sunday you know there's a big difference
one tone can make a difference and of
course it's the same with r whether you
capitalize or not so use lots of
teaching analogies when i teach r and i
really enjoy it because it's great to
support the next generation of
journalists to help them
learn to do the kinds of things that i
do and that i hope to share with you in
a process of my uh talk today um so with
that uh i'll get started i titled my uh
i titled my talk um data or it didn't
happen and i did that very purposefully
because it's one of the main creators
that i use when i um
when i work with uh data for free news
stories um
so the reason i say data or didn't
happen is because without a data story
we often really you know have nothing to
go on to do to our findings
so whether i've been working as a
journalist for
doing stories for usa today or for
propublica or the wall street journal or
reuters you know really throughout my
career everything that i've done all the
big investigative projects
that i've pursued have really had what i
call an empirical spine at their core
and what i mean by that it's really some
central finding that is held up by data
that shows you why the problem it is the
problem that i'm writing about and
spending you know 2 000 or sometimes
5000 words explaining to you why it's
worth your time why you should care and
why it's a big issue
so the reason for that is because you
know a lot of time as journalists the
way newstips find their way to us is you
know someone comes to you and says
usually some version of hey something is
happening you know you should look into
it and it's really important it's a big
deal and you should really look into
this because it's worth a story right um
it's that's generally the approach that
you see people take when they come with
you to you with a news in a new step and
if it's interesting enough and you think
it is worth your time then obviously
you're going to have to go about um
finding uh how it manifests itself in
the real world right where can you find
that uh that sign that what they're
talking about actually is true that it
is happening and it is um you know as
big of a deal as they say it is
so you know in my teaching i've come to
use a phrase that i really like that uh
that i use for this which is uh i call
it imprint of reality because it's
really easy to understand when you think
about the fact that everything from you
know an astronaut stepping on the moon
uh leaving a footprint to you know
physicists trying to find a new
subatomic particle signs of a new
subatomic particle they're all looking
for that imprint of reality that
evidence that the thing they're looking
for you know actually exists
and you know i borrowed that approach
from the scientific method in my work to
basically see if i can find um the
footprint left behind the phenomena by
the phenomenon that i'm investigating
and i assume that for many of you who
are in the data science field um you
take that approach as well it's why you
know
in your profession we use the word data
science right the word science there is
very intentional right and same with
data journalism right
in data journalism we're looking for
that imprint of reality the footprint
left behind by that phenomenon that
we're investigating and so that's what i
go looking for when i find a use tip
that i'm interested in that i think is
worth spending the time on and really
the first thing you know really the
first thing that i go looking for um is
data because data is crucial um and
without it you have no story so hence
the title of this talk uh you know data
or it didn't happen i do mean that you
know quite literally
so with that overview let me give you
just a quick example of what this
actually looks like in real life
so
in 2016 i worked on an international
investigation
that propublica did in coordination with
uh outlets news outlets in germany um
and denmark and the washington post and
basically we had looked we decided to
look into this practice of dividend tax
arbitrage where basically um it's a bit
complicated but uh there's a situation
that we were made aware of where
u.s funds that
share u.s funds that hold shares of
of german stocks
would lend those shares out around the
time of the dividends to funds that were
either exempt from having taxes withheld
or which could claim those taxes back
around dividend after the dividend
was paid and basically saved money on
taxes after shortly after the dividends
were paid the shares that had been lent
out to those tax exempt holders would
make their way back onto the books of
entities that
would have been subject to those
withholdings had they owned the shares
around the dividend time and basically
you know once the deal was done people
would split this proceeds and instead of
having your taxes withheld uh you would
get some portion of that back by
splitting the proceeds with the
tax-exempt investor or the investors who
could claim it back so everyone you know
who participates in the deal wins the
only losers were german taxpayers and
taxpayers in more than 20 other
countries where this was happening but
it was very pronounced in germany had
been happening there for a long time so
we decided to look at germany as a test
case and obviously you know takes kind
of a complicated chart that you see here
to really kind of explain how this works
but um when when you break it down
really if this is all true and it's
happening then it should leave that
imprint in the data right
actually this is happening you should
see around
dividend time the
surge and the demand for shares to be
lent out so that's what i started
looking for i started looking for does
it leave that imprint in the data and
i'll spare you the boring details of how
hard it was to actually get this data
but it did finally manage to get uh
stock loan data for germany's largest
publicly shared uh publicly traded
companies uh known as the dax 30 which
is the main index there and so i got the
data for all of them and i started
looking to see basically if you were
just to map out the number of shares on
loan and compare it against the time
when dividends are paid do you see a
pattern and indeed there was a pattern
it was so pronounced that we call this
chart tax avoidance has a heartbeat
because if no matter which company you
chose you saw this very pronounced
pattern where basically around the
dividend time uh everyone just wanted to
lend their shares up right usually
there's very little demands to borrow
these shares but all of a sudden when
these companies are about to pay
dividends and german companies typically
pay one big dividend a year you know
everyone wanted lend their shares out
and so this was a clear sign that
basically something was indeed going on
here and this phenomenon that the source
had described to us was indeed happening
and this was really um a good example of
how that
that dividend tax avoidance strategy was
so pronounced that it was actually
leaving an imprint in the data and the
stock loan data and this was a really
really pronounced pattern that was just
unmistakable to uh to anyone who would
look at this data so we we put that
together and our story and the the story
ended up having you know tremendous
impact um germany actually passed the
law just shortly after the story ran to
add to to to ban this practice and make
it harder to do these sorts of tax
avoidance deals which is you know really
the main reason why we do these types of
stories right we do them because we want
them to have an impact um and so uh in
this case that happened and
that kind of taught me to bring a data
driven mindset to all of the reporting
that i do
and what i mean by that is that pretty
much anything around us can be turned
into data right whether it's forms and
websites tweets photos you've seen all
these things you know get put together
and turn into structured data
emails you know meeting logs i've gone
through bond sale documents before even
something uh like applause like when a
politician gives a speech like the state
of the union how many times did the
audience break into applause if you
count that you'll have a better more you
know more
detail-rich story so i'm of the mindset
that pretty much anything can be turned
into structured data and that's what i
try to do with my reporting um it's not
always easy and frankly i'll tell you
it's often very hard because a lot of
times you know the data that you're
trying to get out of documents
or whatever other sources you're looking
at you know isn't very easy to extract
i've worked on many stories where it
leads to a situation like this where i'm
literally going through you know dozens
and dozens of
of documents and individually typing in
uh manually inputting data because you
know either the data can't be scanned or
digitized or can't be parsed and really
manual entry ends up being sort of the
only way to do it
so um if you watch the movie uh
spotlight it's very close to reality you
know i i if you haven't watched it yet
please do because it really gives such a
good portrait of what this work can
sometimes be like it can be very boring
and and kind of mind-numbing at times
spending so much time manually inputting
this data but it's very important
because without it you know you'll have
no story so uh they did that very
famously for the uh sexual abuse uh in
the catholic church investigation that
they did and really you know it's a
powerful example of you know how um how
important it can be to really do
everything you can to try to get get
your hands on that data
um luckily uh there are a few time
savers which i'll mention here because
they can be such an important resource
when we get started on these
investigations the three that i want to
mention today is since we're at the our
government conference government
reported data which can be
a terrific resource especially when
you're looking for something that you
know isn't easy to get but there's a
reporting requirement somewhere that
someone must report the data to the
government so government reported data
is the first thing i always try to look
for
secondly i always try to look for
organizations that have already
collected it and put it together in a
into a user-friendly format because you
know user center design is something we
hear a lot about but it isn't always
implemented
especially you know in the public sector
so it's something else to look for is
has anyone else actually collected this
data and put it together in a
user-friendly way that will help you do
your work
faster and then finally i would be
remiss if i didn't mention our favorite
programming language r of course which
makes life a lot easier especially when
you're working with large data sets
so those are the sort of the three time
savers and i want to
spend the rest of the presentation just
give you an
example of how it worked on a recent
project that i worked on earlier this
year
back in the spring i was just finishing
up another project and i got talking
with my editor you know the usual
conversation you have about hey what
should i work on next and he suggested
looking at unemployment insurance fraud
during the pandemic
during the pandemic obviously
unemployment insurance which you can
claim if you lose your job through no
fault of your own had become a crucial
lifeline to millions of americans but uh
months into the pandemic people started
noticing that the weekly new claims
report that the government puts out
showing how many people were claiming
unemployment insurance benefits people
were noticing they just stopped making
sense and so i had seen this story uh
that i have here on the slide from uh
from the economist which they titled
with one of their usual uh puns wild
claims uh talking about how the the
claims data just stopped making sense
and if you were to look at what it was
implying it was basically so many
unemployment insurance claims had been
filed during the pandemic that they
basically implied that you know 50 of
the american workforce was out of a job
and if that's true then obviously we
were facing you know really you know one
much more catastrophic economic downturn
than the one we were in and of course
covet was bad but the economist asked
the smart question you know was it that
bad really does these numbers make sense
and i circled in here the one thing that
really caught my attention in this
article which was they they mentioned in
there that another source of the
distortion in the data could be
widespread fraud so these are questions
things that people were beginning to
think about um and that got me thinking
you know is there room for a story to
look at you know whether fraud was a
factor and if so how widespread was it
and and to do that of course you would
obviously you know the first step at
least in my reporting process is to find
that imprint right to go out there and
look for that imprint that this
phenomenon if it exists the imprint that
i'll be leaving
in the data
so the first thing i did is i actually
started doing a lot of contextual
research just to see what was being said
about fraud were people noticing it and
indeed there were lots of reports
already from the office of inspector
general department of labor um in which
they were pointing out things like this
you know just one of these reports
in this excerpt they mentioned that they
found from just one small sample of the
data they analyzed they found an
instance where someone used one social
security number to file a claim in 40
states and received 222 000 on the same
social security number from 29 states
which obviously shouldn't happen because
you're not allowed to file claims in
more than one state yet people were
clearly doing this um and so that was
one indication that obviously fraud was
a factor and that leaves open the
question well how big of a
factor was it and how many similar
instances were there or other instances
of fraud that you'd be able to document
so one way you might think about doing
this analysis if you get assigned the
story as i did right uh i said i'm
interested count me it's okay let's get
started and one way you might think
about doing it is kind of taking a
bottoms-up approach right and filing
freedom of information act request to
states to get their data and do really
what you would consider like a
bottoms-up analysis of looking at the
individual claims seeing who's filing
them what are the social security
numbers being claimed right does it show
up in other states is the same email or
variance of the same email with dots in
between you know if it's a gmail account
is that showing up in different states
and you could look for those patterns
but to do that you need the
unemployment insurance you know claim
level data and that is actually not
going to be uh possible to get uh via
the freedom information act because uh
in this case you know wouldn't be able
to do much for you um unemployment
insurance insurance claims are exempt
from disclosure under public records law
here's an example of just you know one
state pennsylvania that makes that
abundantly clear on its website and
department of labor and industry before
you even file file on uh freedom of
right to know act requests in their
state they tell you don't don't don't
try trying to getting unemployment
insurance uh claim level data because
it's just not you're not going to get it
it's exempt from disclosure and even the
department of labor's uh office of
inspector general they had trouble
getting this data to get the actual
claims from individual states they had
to file subpoenas with the states to get
this data so it was really hard to get
uh and it was basically going to be
an impossible avenue to use for this
investigation
so you have to come up with something
else and something else for me turned
out to be after doing some more
reporting i realized that i could just
look at aggregate state reported claims
data instead
and try to use that to work out a metric
that would indicate whether
there was something funny or unusual
going on in
in the numbers and the metric that i
worked out that would seem to make the
most sense is to look at well are is the
number of claims that's being filed is
it so large that it actually exceeds the
workforce the the broadest you know
number of people who would possibly even
be eligible to file these claims and if
that's happening happening then it's
clearly a sign that something
something's going wrong right
so i decided to look at that just out of
sheer curiosity and luckily for me in
this instance um the department of labor
has uh copious just lots and lots of
reporting requirements for states they
file reports weekly monthly quarterly
bi-monthly and annually you know
giving all kinds of data to the federal
government about the state of their
unemployment insurance programs how many
claims are being filed you know initial
claims continuing claims first payments
just all kinds of data which they post
here and they update very frequently and
you can get those reports along with the
reporting instructions examples of what
the actual forms look like right and you
can get into that and really start doing
you know whatever analysis you want to
do um and even more you know this is
helpful but it's you know it's not
really user-centric design right there's
uh it's good that it's there but it's
not necessarily the easiest uh
to work with as a starting point but at
least at least it's there so i looked
around and turned out that the century
foundation had actually created an
entire unemployment insurance data
dashboard where they downloaded this
data and they made it available on
github they created
unemployment an unemployment insurance
data portal using shiny and r which is
great
and they made it available for anyone to
download and start using and do their
own analyses so i thought this is great
this is a terrific starting point so i
use that to
then
create a script that would help me
basically make sense of this data and so
what i ended up doing was writing this
script uh which i just ran today and it
still works so yay for reproducible
workflows still works and i commented it
very copiously so i can still understand
uh you know six months on what's going
on which is always good but basically
what it did was it downloaded the data
and put it in uh created all sorts of
summary reports that would help me
basically understand uh you know state
by state how many initial claims are
being filed and then i compared that
against some relevant metrics of the
labor market the department of labor has
a report that they started putting
together uh a while back that estimates
the number of layoffs month by month so
you can actually see an estimate for how
many people are laid off in each state
each month
so use that as a denominator to look at
you know claims uh over a period of
march to december of 2020 and to total
up the claims versus the total layoffs
over that period and then to also
secondly you know compare that um the
number of claims over that period
against the pre-pandemic uh labor force
to see how many people were actually in
the labor force before the pandemic hit
and then comparing that and calculating
these and a bunch of other ratios to
basically do
you know what i call a contextual
analysis to look at the context
surrounding this data and to basically
you know scratch your head and say does
it make sense right and so i put that
together i mapped it out using your
ggplot and the the us maps
package which i love and it allowed me
to really get a good sense of what was
going on and um true to what others had
been saying you know the the data really
wasn't making much sense um if you look
at it this is one of the out one of the
maps i put together so this just mapped
out initial jobless claims from march to
december 2020 and just looked at it as a
share of each state's pre-covered labor
force and there were several states
where the number of claims filed just in
that short period actually eclipsed the
the entire labor force of the state
right which
doesn't make sense right you shouldn't
have more people filing for unemployment
insurance than you have people who are
actually eligible who are
worker workers in the state and so in
arizona was really bad and
in arizona and rhode island the states
that were putting out press releases and
talking about um talking about fraud
were actually the ones who were you know
showing up in in
these darker colors in here
and then when i calculated as a
percentage of layoffs i got an even more
alarming you know map because you know
in state after state you saw that the uh
claims that were being reported were
actually you know many cases many
multiples of the layoffs that happened
during that time period
so that led to this data graph that we
put together for the story um in which
you know we kind of summarize the the
the findings of the analysis it's
something you always do in a data-driven
story and we said that nobody has yet
come too close to putting a definitive
number on it but the data hints that
there has been fraud uh in the system
and it's uh and it's it had potentially
has a massive scope um the number of
initial claims you know nationwide
equated to about 60 percent of the
country's pre-pandemic labor force and
in five states arizona georgia hawaii
nevada and rhode island it actually
outnumbered the entire pool of civilian
workers and if you compare that against
the number of workers who had lost their
jobs you know just numbers really
weren't making sense so it was clear
there were some other potential
explanations but it was def it was
definitely uh the case that fraud you
know was that it was uh a factor here
and it
could explain some of uh if not a
significant portion of these elevated
claims
figures that we were seeing so we had we
married that with some additional uh you
know uh underground reporting just uh or
on the present hong kong time so you
know uh
not quite on the ground but uh doing
some additional research
to look at what was going on we found uh
bots filing fake claims you know one
company that was working with states to
try to prevent these fake claims um they
had detected 23 000 claims coming from
just one macbook air computer um there
was you know there were telegram chat
rooms which were aiding fraud in which
people were just openly talking about
methods for filing fraud um fake claims
poured in from around the world and they
often got paid um you know we're talking
about uh you know situations like one
state that had ip addresses from 70
different countries where people were
trying to get
file claims and states were understaffed
and under resourced to deal with the
fraud you know in kansas they had 33
workers for their call center to take
calls in april of 2020 at the time they
got 12.5 million calls so uh you can do
the math for how many people actually
got through to get help with their claim
when they ran into trouble or you know
couldn't uh have their claims stopped
because someone was filing a fake claim
in their name so that's how the story
came together it was a really of an
important reporting project because it
shed light on how big of a problem this
really was i encourage you to check it
out it's still
um it's a it's still up on propublica
website it's a really um you know
exhaustive analysis of everything that's
sort of gone wrong
in this area and why we saw you know so
much fraud during the pandemic
and i want to close just by very briefly
um giving some lessons since we're at an
our government conference
for how i think the uh the public sector
and journalists can work together when
we pursue these sort of large
data-driven investigative projects but
the first thing is to follow reporting
obligations right because two plus two
should equal four and whether it's
kansas new york illinois or any other
state and if it equals five in one of
those states and obviously we have a
problem uh one of the issues that
happened was some states were you know
reporting the data in different ways or
they were reporting with a huge lag or
they weren't reporting the data at all
and so that led to obviously issues that
made it more difficult not just for
journalists but also for academics and
others to analyze this data so
it's important to follow reporting
obligations when you have them and to
report the data in a consistent fashion
the way the federal government requires
it and to do it as quickly and as
consistently as you can because it makes
your life easier and everyone's life
easier
secondly make the data easy to access
it's great that the department of labor
had it all sitting out there but again
we hear a lot about user centered design
these days and i think
thinking about that and taking it into
account when you're designing those data
portals is really important because the
easier you can make the data more
accessible via an api can make it much
easier to work with
and then finally you know please answer
questions you know most importantly you
know when journalists like me when they
come to you
a lot of times we're not necessarily
looking for a quote we're just looking
for insights to help us understand and
make sense of things you know as i
mentioned in the case of unemployment
insurance data this is what the form
looks like right uh for regular claims
just for uh or for this uh this is for
the for for one of the claim programs
you can see that um it's not you know
very it's very clear what's going where
but it's not necessarily easy to figure
out how to make sense of it so i had to
find people who could help me do that
i'm really really grateful for them
because
this is an example of the answer i got
from uh
an answer that i got to a question i
sent to someone about what
how to make sense of the data and how to
aggregate and i'm really glad this is
the only time in my career that someone
sent me an actual table to answer a
question uh because it was a bit
complicated and help me make sense of it
and so getting this sort of leveled uh
this level of detail to an uh to an into
a question is really helpful and just
really impressed on me and i hope to
impress on you that you know it's really
important to answer questions if you're
going to put data out there whether it's
through an api a government data portal
or something else it's important of a
point person designated who will work
with people and try to answer those
questions
so that let's all go out there and find
those imprints uh in in the data for
whatever it is you're investigating or
looking at whether you're a data
scientist or public uh sector in the
public sector whatever it is you're
doing i wish you all the best good luck
go find those imprints and i'd love to
stay in touch uh here's my contact info
don't be afraid to reach out and thank
you so much for having me really
appreciate the opportunity to share some
of my knowledge with you all today
thank you very much for that talk
it was a pleasure seeing you after all
these years uh hopefully one day i'll
see you in person again
absolutely same here